let's bring in Ross Tucker Ross Tucker
football podcast Westwood One NFL
analyst calling the Titans Ravens games
Saturday night former NFL offensive
lineman and host of home at home on
radio.com
app and calling the Titans Ravens game
Ross thanks for joining us
nobody's come up with a game plan this
year to stop the Ravens and Lamar
Jackson
what will the Titans do that will be
different this weekend then that is the
question and I'm sure Dean P's and Mike
Vrabel will try to come up with
something you know it's weird because
the Titans are the only team in the AFC
playoffs that haven't already played the
Ravens now I personally think that
that's a disadvantage because I think
when you go against the Ravens it's
almost like going against army or Navy
or Air Force right in college football
you're your scout team just can't really
replicate it very well I know they had
Mariota trying to do it this week it's
just not the same their running backs to
linemen they have a tough time
replicating the mesh point and how they
do everything and so what happens is you
get out there in the game your scout
team didn't do a great job and now
everything so much faster than you
thought it would be next thing you know
they go down they score the first two
touchdowns this happened almost every
game they've played it's the same way
when you play the academy's or the
option teams so I do think it's an
advantage for the Ravens that unlike the
Texans of the Chiefs or the Patriots
this will be the first time the Titans
are getting a look at it the flipside
though would be you know maybe they
could come up with something different
but Dan people have tried everything
yeah I mean they tried to hit Lamar as
much as they can they tried to take away
the dive and Lamar run they've tried to
take away Lamar given that I mean it's
if there was something new to be tried I
would think that everyone else would
have been able to at least give it a
shot over the last 14 weeks my guess is
they'll try to mix it up and confuse
them our Jackson personally I would take
out Lamar on every play that would be
the focus I
take my chances with the running backs
you know getting five to seven yards up
the middle but what is different this
year as opposed to this Lamar Jackson in
these Ravens last year when they bowed
out against the Chargers it's a great
question and the answer is the offense
has evolved and they've committed more
to it which by the way is unbelievable
like there are quotes you know prepping
for the game Dan that in the Ravens
media notes they have a quote from John
Harbaugh saying in May in May during
OTAs I think we're gonna revolutionize
the way football is played in the NFL I
think we're gonna change the game I mean
if they go on to win the Super Bowl and
they got a great chance that's like one
of the all-time calling your shots I
mean in May to say we're gonna change
and then they do it I mean it's like he
gave everybody fair warning he told
everybody this was coming and now it is
so what they've done is they've built on
they only had a couple of run game
concepts with Lamar Jackson last year
this year they've built on that and then
the whole passing game is now based off
of all of the run action stuff and when
you have a guy like Eric Weddle who was
35 years old played forever saying he
didn't know where the ball was half the
time when the Rams played the Raven
that's a pretty good indicator of part
of the reason why the Ravens are having
so much success
give me the team that has the best
chance of pulling off the upset
Vikings absolutely Vikings I don't
understand
this betting line for the second weekend
in a row I thought the Saints were
giving them too many points I think the
Saints are a better team right now than
the 49ers I mean Dan the Vikings have a
top eight quarterback in Kirk Cousins
top five running back Dalvin cook top
five wide receiver duo
Fionan big top 5 d n duo Griffin and
Daniel hunter Kendricks is an all-pro
linebacker they're battle tested they've
played in a lot of playoff games last
couple years I don't get it I mean I
still think the Niners maybe win like 24
23 but I love the Vikings with the
points I think
a true toss-up game the only real
advantage I think for San Francisco is
there coming off a bye and it's a short
week for the Vikings but especially
after they went down there and whipped
up on the Saints those guys are feeling
sky hiring I mean that was no fluke Dan
they dominated a game frankly if it
wasn't for Taysom Hill that might have
been a blowout would you rather have
Kirk Cousins or Jimmy Garoppolo for this
game are moving forward this game this
game out go cousins and now listen
everybody say Oh Jimmy Gees first
playoff game Jimmy G's for listen to me
I mean think about what Garoppolo did
down there in New Orleans against the
Saints or the two third and six teens
against the Rams in a game they had to
have or how he played against the
Seahawks week 17
I mean Garoppolo has come up big in a
bunch of clutch situations recently and
deserves a lot of credit for that but I
just think Cousins has kind of been
there done that has a little bit more to
prove and I think he's got a better
receiving corps and they're feeling it
after they won I'm telling you right now
Dan the winner of that game is going to
the Super Bowl the winner of the Niners
and the Vikings to go in the Super Bowl
because if it's the Niners then they're
gonna host either Green Bay or Seattle
in the conference championship game and
I feel good about them winning that if
it's the Vikings
I don't care do they have to go on the
road in Minnesota after they would have
won at the Superdome in at San Francisco
that would tell me that those guys are
playing at a really high level either
way I think the winner of that game is
going the Super Bowl we're talking to
Ross Tucker he'll be on the broadcast
for Westwood one Titans and ravens
that'll be Saturday night the Cleveland
Browns looks like they're zeroing in on
Josh McDaniels
if that's the case what do you think I
like it
I played for Josh no.5 and no.6 in New
England he's extremely bright and the
aspects of it that I like from a Browns
perspective are number one he's from
there so immediately that will
ingratiate him with the fans what you
think is a positive but from a strictly
football state
been a head coach before now I would
have loved Ron Rivera or Mike McCarthy
in Cleveland because of their track
record of success as head coaches and
the idea that they could get Odell and
Jarvis Landry and Baker Mayfield to fall
in line with what they say they've got
kind of those strong personalities but I
do think McDaniels has enough cachet
having been in New England this long all
the Super Bowls Tom Brady's coach etc
but I do think he'll get those guys to
listen and they'll believe that he can
put them in the best position to succeed
he also loved Baker Mayfield coming out
I think he'll be able to say to Baker
and show Baker some of the things that
Tom did on end off the field to get
Baker to be a little bit more Brady
asked as a man who once blocked for Tom
Brady or at least tried to block for
John Brady right yeah what where do you
think Brady is going to be next year I
still think it's New England I think
when it comes down to it I think Brady
wants to be in New England
I think Macabre craft definitely doesn't
want him going anywhere else the wild
card to me is really Belichick you know
it's been well documented the Belichick
did not want to move on from Jimmy
Garoppolo and I wonder if Belichick
starts to push back on craft a little
bit I don't think they'll attack were
given an ultimatum per se but he might
say listen you know we did this once but
now it's not now we got to move on Bob
Orr does Belichick try to grind Brady on
the contract I think he probably will
and Dan honestly I think Tom's just sick
of it you know I mean they've grinded
him on the contract so many times even
though he's been so unselfish in that
regard I think he's kind of annoyed with
the way things have gone from a contract
standpoint and from the personnel around
him this year the last couple years I
think he wants to be back but I think if
they lowball him or give them flak about
I think he's gonna be like you know what
forget it I'm out of here I'm out of
here too and so are you
now good luck have fun in Baltimore on
Saturday night the Titans Ravens
Westwood One and of course the Ross
Tucker football podcast great to talk to
you again hey congratulations on the
Hall of Fame thank you thank you Ross I
appreciate them that's Ross Tucker for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]